hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the 2021 fiji world cup
uh it's another game you guys have
requested young sister of duda versus
vidit and it's
quite an incredible one the first game
ended in a draw this is the second game
and it features 720 moves of crude
theory so we're not going to dwell too
long on that
but after that it really uh you know
becomes a great
great game and it features two very very
cool positive video moments
uh i mean maybe i've already mentioned
that but uh
you know you guys will enjoy this one so
let's see what happened and why so many
of you have requested this game so do
that with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and like we said bishop to
b5 the rule lopez is on the board with
a6 uh morphy's defense bishop to a4 and
now
knight to f6 we have castles by duda and
divided attacks the bishop with b5
bishop to b3 and bishop to c5 now the
bishop can later
on go to b6 a7 this bishop is coming to
b7 so hoping for a nice
bishop game pair uh a bishop pair game
and here while c3 is the most often
played move uh
duda strikes on the flank with a4
attacking that b5 pawn
uh we have rooked a b8 and now c3
uh if you remember a few days ago we had
this uh variation knight captures on e5
and then after knight captures d4 which
is also a lot of fun
uh but here uh we have c3 going for a
uh for a well more of a comm approach uh
we have d6
and now d4 now striking in the center
attacking the bishop here
bishop to b6 and now a5 and this is also
something we've seen many times on this
channel
uh the point is if uh you capture with
the bishop then the bishop no longer
i you know is involved with with the
struggle for the central squares
and if you capture with the knight then
we simply give up the rook rook captures
bishop captures
and you will have problems here the
captures e captures and now we trade
queens captures captures knight captures
on e5
and it's gonna be uh well it's not gonna
be easy for black to defend this black
is up the exchange but
you're going to lose the f7 pawn and
it's uh well
a better position for white so of course
everyone avoids this after a5 we have
bishop back to a7
and now h3 taking away the g4 square
from black's pieces
we have bishop to b7 now that its bishop
perry is very nicely placed here
and bishop to e3 now another well-known
pawn sacrifice
uh but also it is the best move for
black so that it captures at night
captures on e4
and now d5 attacking the bishop and
the knight ended the bishop on a7 so
bishop captures an e3
we have d captures in c6 and now knight
captures an f2 attacking the queen and
threatening a lot of very nasty
discoveries
and this has all been played before so
nothing new here queen to e2
attacking the bishop and now a double
check knight captures an h3 check from
the bishop and the knight
and as you know the quote goes even the
bravest king
flees in the face of a double check so
king the h1
and now knight back to f2 with check and
now
you have to capture here there is no
other way around it if you go king to g1
then knight g4 check and you will have
problems here with white for example
king h1 black can just castle
and uh it's it's just bad we have to
capture the bishop on b7 but now e4 we
attack the knight
knight h2 we're gonna capture on h2 and
now our rook is under attack here
so we can't capture with the king then
we get queen to h4 check bishop
covers the g1 square we have to go for
this rook captures on f7 line
real captures bishop captures with king
captures and now
queen captures an e3 so a nice capture
fest here
knights to g4 attacks the queen queen f4
check
uh attacks the knight knight f6
defending and now
uh you have this position where black is
just up material for example knight e2
we go after the pawn queen e7 we
defended rook to e1 adding another
attacker d5 we defend it and black is
just better here
so uh this has been all been analyzed
many many times so of course no one
plays this but just in case you were
wondering
so rook captures on f2 this is by far
the best bishop captures and now we
reach a position that has been reached
before
but in all of the games c captures on b7
was played exclusively
it kind of makes sense because you don't
want to allow this bishop to capture and
then
for black to have this beautiful light
square bishop along this diagonal
so uh there's a known game uh where
grishok
and geary played this to a draw and also
mvl and
levon arunyan played this uh where levon
defeated mvl
uh but in both of those games see
capture some b7 was played but here we
have queen captures on f2 by duda
and it is now only as of move 18 that we
have a completely new game
so now let's see how vidiq plays this he
has to capture the
the pawn here otherwise uh you know his
position
kinda is bad but maybe he can play
bishop to c8 maybe that's kind of the
point of this line
uh and why it was not attempted before
maybe bishop to c8 is just a safer move
but he played bishop captures on c6 and
now duda goes
knight captures on e5 and now there's a
triple attack here this pawn this
knight and the queen are attacking f7
and also the knight is attacking the
bishop here and you can't capture
the knight because then still it's
checkmate from the queen and the bishop
so you have to
play the only move available to you and
that is bishop captures on g2 very very
complicated move
uh and uh white has to ignore this he
has to play king to g1 the problem with
capturing is
i'm going to show you if you capture
with the king we go we deliver queen to
g5 check and now the queen will simply
pick up the knight here
if king f1 we're gonna play queen
captures on e5 and now even if queen
captures an f7 king the eighth
black is fine here there is nothing to
worry about if bishop to e6 trying to
checkmate the black king we can always
play queen f6 check trade queens
and uh yes white does have a bishop and
the knight for a rook but black is up
three pawns so you know
uh if anyone's to be preferred here it's
it's definitely black
and on the other hand if um after this
bishop captures on g2
uh you capture with the queen which is
also possible still queen to h4
check king to g1 now queen to e1 check
again connects with the knight we're
gonna play queen to f1 to also again
uh access to the f7 square but now queen
to g3 check and now
um uh you know you you can do a lot of
things but now for example
queen g2 queen captures an e5 and black
will always be better here as
now this is nicely defended so there are
no worries here so
after bishop captures on g2 king the g1
this is by far the best and now comes
queen to f6
uh but it has to defend somehow and it's
not easy
you could also consider castling uh it's
a definitely possible
uh but if it went for queen to f6 he
offered a queen trade but now of course
we're going to capture on f7 knight
captures on f7
queen captures an f2 with check king
captures and now
rook to f8 so you have to kind of
capture on g2
king captures on g2 rook captures an f7
bishop captures an f7
and now king captures an f7 and now uh
white is up a piece as you can see it's
uh rook and knight against the rook but
black is up three pawns so three pawns
against the knight
uh but you know what they say inches a
knight is a knight
uh the great man once said that and it
was not soon two
uh you know you know who it was so after
king captures an f7
we have to somehow activate our pieces
so knight to d2 by duda
and rook to e8 of course the video puts
the rook on the
open e file we rook the f1 check king to
g6
and now king to f2 so you have to take
away all of the
important squares from the black rook so
the black rook cannot be activated
uh we have h5 if it starts pushing his
pass pawn
rook to g1 with check king f6 and now
king to f3
grabbing more space with the king all of
these scores are now nicely covered so
the black rook cannot enter the game
g6 by visit and now knight to e4
with check so that it goes back king to
g7
and now knight to f2 so what do you play
here
uh well we have rook to f8 with check
king to g2 and now rook
back to e8 with the idea of going for
rook to e2 but now
uh duda shows that this isn't really a
threat he plays knight
to d3 and now this check doesn't really
do anything if you deliver this checking
f3
and what you do the b2 point is defended
by the knight there's really not all
that much for the rook to do here
so after knight to d3 we have g5 but it
continues pushing his past pawn
now comes knight to b4 going after the
a6 pawn
we have rook to e2 with check connecting
with the b2 pawn
king to h1 so uh dudas king is quite
quite passive here but you know it seems
to be working out for him rook captures
on b2
uh and now what do you play here it's a
very very sensitive position only one
move here is winning for white so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this winning idea for duda
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding
knight captures on a6 that's a nice move
but it's not the winning
a winning one we're gonna show why it's
not winning even though it kind of looks
like it's winning
uh it might be winning but you know
maybe with uh you know
alpha zero like precision uh but uh the
the really winning move is rook to a1
this is what the duda played and we're
going to
see why this is so so capturing on a6
right away
it looks incredible but the problem is
now we're going to play
rook to a2 now we attack this pawn we
attack the knight
and of course then uh we're going to be
attacking the knight
so here rook the g5 check it seems like
white is in time to defend
the a5 pawn with the rook king f6 now
we're going to play
rook cactus and b5 defend our pawn here
but now comes
c6 we're gonna play rook captures on h5
again it seems like white is defending
everything but now king to g6 and now
look at this the pawns
and the king are taking away the entire
fifth rank from the white rook
and now the white rook uh has to abandon
the defense of the a5 pawn for example
rook h2 or rook h3 and now rook captures
on a5
and this might be winning but you know
you're going to have to really grind it
out so instead after rook captures on b2
congratulations to everyone who found
rook to a1 because now black really uh
does not have a good move because next
we're going to capture and
this pawn will be defended forever so
here we have c5
attacking the knight if it of course uh
finds counter play right away he's
planning to play b4 and create a pass
pawn of his own
knight captures on a6 and now b4 and uh
for those of you who saw all the way to
this position
uh while deciding to play rook to a1 and
now uh
found a move then really congratulations
you you should not be watching this
channel
but for those of you who are interested
in figuring out how to continue here
there is again only one winning move
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for duda while i give you a
couple of seconds
for the second time
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
uh you know figuring it out uh a night
is always a night uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight captures on
b4 this is by far
uh the absolute best move the probably
the only winning move in the position
and there's really nothing for black to
do here
uh in the game c characters on b4 was
played but now
a6 we have b captures on c3 now comes a7
c2 and now a8 queen uh but now
visit plays rook to b1 with check and
now if you capture we're gonna
bring a queen into the game with check
so obviously we're not gonna do that
so king to g2 and now comes c1 with
queen so if you look at the position now
uh vidit is up material he's up three
pawns the problem is
uh dudas uh du duda has the move uh
and well the king is in g7 not defended
by anything
so rook to a7 check and now we start our
march from the thumbnail
uh king to f6 we have queen to f8 with
check
king to e5 we have rook to e7 with check
king to d5 and now queen to f3 with
check forcing the king to the c file and
then rook to
c7 will be will be deadly if you try to
avoid this
it's not really going to work or
whatever you try you will always end up
on the c file
so king the c5 was played right away
rook to c7
check and now king to b4 and now you
don't want to capture the queen even
though i know a lot of you guys were
you know thinking about this because if
captures and captures it's a rook in
three pawns against the queen
white will win this in the end but
there's no there's no reason to give
black any counter play
so here we have queen to b7 with chuck
king to a5
and now comes queen to a7 with check
king to b5
now comes queen to b8 with check freeing
up the a7 square for the rook
and he was in this position uh on move
50 that vidiq resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done
whatever you play king a5 king a6 king
a4 uh
next move is the same by wife k4 rook
the a7 will be checkmate
so as there is nothing more to be done
here vidiq resigned and this is uh well
a very sad moment for him as he came
uh so close to getting to that
semi-final match and it's a
really really important because once you
get into the semi-finals uh there's only
four of you left and
two of the uh uh two of the top uh
placed uh players uh get an invitation
into the candidates tournament
and this one of them is magnus carlsen
uh who is already invited to the
candidates tournament regardless
well i mean if he if he loses the match
against depot he's
automatically in the candidates
tournament so magnus can never take away
your spot at the candidates and
of course he's a world champion so he's
not going to play the candidates so even
if he loses the match to nipple
he will not be taking your spot in the
candidates tournament so you have a
really really awesome shot
of uh getting into the candidates by by
winning this match and duda won the
match so
duda is now very very close to uh being
one of the contenders in the next video
candidates tournament so really really
awesome stuff for him
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh it
took a very very nice preparation as
you've seen uh 20 moves of pure theory
everything's been played before and it
all came down to this move
after bishop captures an f2 both grishok
and mvl
played uh this move c captures on b7 but
duda found
queen captures an f2 a move that has
been played before and then
it kind of just all came together for
him and he was able to win this game
very nicely
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank psp jaroslav
lubelski
matthew benoit vladilattrulu studios in
dario pavlovic for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
soon continuing the coverage of the
v-day um
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day